(Anna laughs)
(audience claps)
So you're working at Zagat, you're fact checking,
you're signature dishing.
(Anna laughs)
You have your illustrious acting career
in the rear-view mirror.
Where are you at and what brings you back?
See, I would say my illustrious acting career
was ahead of me at that point,
because what was behind me was not my choice, right?
But in front of me was living in New York,
going to see Broadway shows all the time,
standing in the TKTS line and getting to see Broadway.
And that was when it really started,
kind of the Jiminy Cricket on my shoulder saying,
you should try this again, yeah.
But was that the only voice
that told you to go back to acting?
There was like a...
for about a month, I was getting these signs from just-
The universe?
Jung would've called it the synchronicity.
And yeah, I met Roberta Flack at a nail salon.
Just wacky.
And I met her and she asked what I was doing.
I said, "Oh, I'm done with show business."
And she looked at me like I had seven heads
and she was like, why would you not?
So it just stuck with me.
And then the straw that broke the camel's back
was I was on a lunch break crying,
'cause you cry on a lunch break when you're sad
and in your 20s sometimes.
I love you.
(Anna laughs)
Go on.
I'm walking towards Madison Avenue to get a burger,
and there was a psychic who was always handing out
her pamphlets on 53rd and Madison.
And she was, you know, "Oh, I have a question for you."
And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah."
That's what you say, that's what you say to advertise.
And she followed me and...
she poked on my shoulder.
I turn around,
you know, a mess.
And she's like, "I have a question."
I'm like, "What?"
She says, "Are you the girl from 'My Girl'?"
I'm like, "Ugh, yes." (laughs)
You know, great psychic, and so then-
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
But then she says...
Then she said, "You're not done, you still wanna do this."
Then I was like, (groans)
I mean, it was...
It was $40 for a 10 minute palm reading on my lunch break.
On an editorial assistant's salary,
$40 on a lunch break really meant a lot to me.
But I did, I got my palm read.
But really the message was, you need to try this again.
You aren't done, you're wondering if you need to try.
And so that stuck with me, yeah.
(audience claps)
And you saw this psychic.
There's a pack of tarot cards here.
(Anna laughs)
How did this come about?
You read tarot cards?
I do.
This is years later now.
This is 20 years later.
Do they connect?
This, you know...
How do I start?
I first saw my first deck of tarot,
I think my dad brought it into the house
'cause he was exploring our Roma heritage.
That's our heritage which is always very connected
with psychics and tarot,
and dancing bears and whatever.
And we have that in our heritage too.
And then I didn't look at it for a long, long time.
And then I was in a play in 2018
at Second Stage with an actor named Stephen Park
who reads tarot.
And so we got used to everyday just pulling a card.
And once that show was over
and he was no longer in my life everyday with his cards-
You missed it.
I missed it.
And I learned and I learned.
(upbeat bright music)